die proteste gegen die korona maßnahmen
und die impfpflicht sie reißen einfach
nicht ab auch am abend kam es in
mehreren deutschen städten zu teils
gewaltsamen demonstrationen in rostock
karlsruhe und magdeburg etwa
versammelten sich tausende menschen
meist auch nicht angemeldeten
demonstration
kam es zu zahlreichen ausschreitungen
polizeibeamte mussten eingreifen und
stießen bei einigen demonstranten auf
vehemente gegenwehr
magdeburg und rostock wurden
polizeiketten gewaltsam durchbrochen
mehrere personen wurden daraufhin
festgenommen der kurz zuvor war die
konferenz der länderchefs mit dem
bundeskanzler zu den crooner maßnahmen
zu ende gegangen das unspektakuläre
ergebnis im wesentlichen weiter so viel
spektakulärer
spektakulärer das muss man aussprechen
denn es war so war der zoff um
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach bei
den bürgern ist er zwar deutschlands
beliebtester politiker bei den
ministerpräsidenten dagegen keinesfalls
nachdem das robert koch institut das im
jahr unterstellt ist ohne abstimmung und
über nacht den genesenen status von
sechs auf drei monate verkürzt hatte
hessens cdu ministerpräsident volker
bouffier schimpfte zitate dieses
verhalten hat viel vertrauen zerstört
hier sehen wirst nicht nur bei mir dass
es egal sondern bei vielen menschen im
land thüringens regierungschef bodo
ramelow von der linken fühlte sich
hintergangen ich habe persönlich mit dir
karl gesprochen und karl hatte offenbar
nichts über seine pläne gesagt ja und
selbst manuela schwesig
ministerpräsidenten von mecklenburg
vorpommern und wie lauterbach in der spd
kritisierte das vorgehen als
unglücklich ja und bei uns im studio ist
philipp hofft philipp er lasst uns erst
mal kurz über diesen genesenen staaten
sprechen der wurde ja verkürzt wir haben
es gerade gesagt von sechs auf drei
monate das gilt fürs volk aber nicht für
die volksvertreter das wirklich ganz
genau dass bundes der bundestag der
deutsche bundestag hat sich ausgerechnet
bei diesem thema ein corona sonderrecht
gegönnt eine richtige extrawurst und
zwar hat das lka wie ihr schon gesagt
habe beschlossen dass der genesenen
status in ganz deutschland verkürzt wird
das gilt für alle deutschen von sechs
monate auf drei monate und die
bundesländer haben sich danach
auszurichten viele haben auch ihre
verordnung schon angepasst nur der
deutsche bundestag hält an seiner
verordnung fest es gibt so eine
sogenannte allgemeinverfügung ich habe
gestern angefragt und mir wurde bescheid
gesagt nein bei uns gilt es weiterhin
sechs monate das heißt ein normaler
mensch der zur arbeit geht und dessen
infektion vier monate her ist der gilt
nicht mehr als genesen da muss sich also
testen lassen im deutschen bundestag ist
das nicht so da geht man sechs monate
lang als genesen und kommt also
problemlos in die räume industrie
bekommt die immunität der abgeordneten
noch mal eine ganz neue bedeutung als
absolut vielleicht hat man das mit der
immunität einfach falsch verstanden aber
das absurde ist ja dass der deutsche
bundestag das erst möglich gemacht hat
das der genesenen status verkürzt wird
der deutsche bundestag hat dass er mit
beschlossen dass das
robert-koch-institut es überhaupt
entscheiden darf die haben die melker er
diese vollmacht sozusagen auf dem
goldenen teller serviert neuen ich das
ja noch ändern in zukunft aber bleibt
das jetzt erst mal ich habe auch dazu
gefragt und dazu gab es man würde sagen
blabla denn man beobachtet die lage man
schaut sich an was die
ministerpräsidenten beschließt man
beobachtet das infektionsgeschehen und
wird fortwährend analysieren ob eine
änderung zu gegebener zeit angemessen
ist also also die ak ii das
robert-koch-institut hat diese
veränderungen vorgenommen das
robert-koch-institut untersteht karl
lauterbach karl lauterbach deshalb
entsprechend in der schusslinie und der
bundeskanzler der karl lauterbach
womöglich ja selber gar nicht im amt
haben wollte aber sozusagen auf druck
der öffentlichkeit ihnen in diesem job
gehievt hat sich jedenfalls gestern
benötigt in der pressekonferenz nach der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
seinen gesundheitsminister zu
verteidigen wir an
den bundesgesundheitsminister hat von
mir die unterstützung bekommen die er
braucht und die auch krieg muss
ganz großartiger minister ist und in
dieser frage hoch engagiert und es hat
eigentlich jeder gesagt dass er sehr
engagiert diese arbeit macht ich glaube
sogar parteiübergreifend lässt sich das
festhalten insofern war ich vielleicht
genannte das besonders gerne gemacht hat
aber viele andere auch nur
in der fußball bundesliga erst einmal so
wenn der vorstandschef so war s sagt
dann ist der trainer kurz vom
rausschmiss absolut ist es kein gutes
zeichen wenn olaf scholz sich vor ein
minister stellen muss das zeigt er dass
etwas falsch läuft sonst gäbe es ja gar
keinen grund sich vor ihn zu stellen und
das carlotta brachte gerade so viel
anerkennung
parteiübergreifend gar für seine arbeit
bekommt würde ich nichts sagen ihr habt
das vorgelesen diese zitate von den
ministerpräsidenten die haben mit ihm
abgerechnet die fühlen sich von ihm
hintergangen und zwar gab es am 14
januar eine bundesratssitzung karl
lauterbach und die ministerpräsidenten
und er hat ihnen gesagt keine sorge wir
werden euch rechtzeitig informieren
bevor der genesenden status verkürzt
wird oder bevor der geimpften status
geändert wird ihr werdet das rechtzeitig
erfahren niemand von euch wird
überrascht und dann geht aus dieser
bundestags bundesratssitzung raus und
plötzlich ändert das lka überraschend
seine vorgaben und die
ministerpräsidenten erfahren aus dem
internet oder aus der bild zeitung dass
der gelesenen status verkürzt wurde und
millionen bürger wurden kalt erwischt
aber umso erstaunlicher ist es
eigentlich und da wollen wir jetzt mal
drauf schauen liebe zuschauer dass
politiker ranking das
beliebtheitsranking der politiker denn
karl lauterbach ist immer noch auf platz
eins und das vor olaf scholz und auch
christian lindner die man ja jetzt
eigentlich auf dem ersten platz vermutet
hätte was sagst du dazu
karl lauterbach ist auf platz eins erst
der politiker der die größte
medienpräsenz hat er ist das corona
gesicht das gesicht der pandemie und das
weit vorne mit 53,7 absolut absolut ich
würde sagen und dann diese zahlen
sprechen absolut für sicher ist der
beliebteste politiker dar und darüber
kann man nicht streiten ich würde aber
auch sagen dass er der umstrittenste
politiker ist ich glaube dass karl
lauterbach bei den menschen für eine
polarisierung sorgt ich glaube viele
menschen mögen ihn vermutlich mehr
menschen
vermutlich mögen mehr menschen als
menschen die nicht mögen aber es gibt
eben auch glaube ich ganz viele bei
denen er negative gefühle ausgelöst bei
denen ablehnung auslöst und mit solchen
regelungen mit so einer überraschenden
verkürzung des genesenen status der sich
für millionen menschen verheerend
auswirkt die verlieren einfach über
nacht ihre rechte können nicht mehr ohne
test bus und bahn fahren können nicht
mehr ins restaurant gehen plötzlich weil
sie nicht mehr als genesen zählen mit
sowas verspielt er natürlich vertrauen
bei den menschen aber auch bei den
ministerpräsidenten und ich sage diese
geschichte dieser krimi ist noch nicht
vorbei karl-otto mache dieser affäre
noch nicht ausgestanden also bei den
bürgern topf bei den kollegen flop kann
man so sagen es ist ja in der tat wie du
sagst wir haben auf der einen seite ist
er umstritten erwirkt immer so ein
bisschen wie der zerstreute professor
andererseits gerade dadurch
unterstellt man eben auch dass er
aufrichtig und authentisch ist
karl lauterbach behauptet seit beginn
der pandemie dass er immer einzig und
allein wissenschaftlichen maßgaben
fordert ich würde sagen das stimmt nicht
und das ist jetzt in dieser affäre um
den genesenen status besonders deutlich
geworden denn karl lauterbach sagt zwei
jahr der genesenden status wurde auf
drei monate verkürzt allein aus
wissenschaftlichen gründen studien
hätten gezeigt dass man als genesen
nicht so lange geschützt ist ehrlich
gesagt die begründung des lkw war total
dürftig die haben einfach irgendwelche
studien verlinkt auf ihrer webseite und
der bürger kann sich dann selbst
zusammen lesen wo das was das rkw
behauptet in diesen studien begründet
ist ich finde das absolut unzureichend
aber der sprecher von karl lauterbach
hat in der bundespressekonferenz noch
einen weiteren wichtigen satz gesagt und
zwar und man solle diese verkürzung auch
als anreiz zum impfen verstehen und das
ist für mich eine politische begründung
und keine wissenschaftliche und mit
sowas verspielt lauterbach vertrauen bei
der bevölkerung dreht sich ja gestern
die alles um die personalie karl
lauterbach was ist denn eigentlich ganz
kurz noch mal auf den punkt herum
gekommen bei der mpk gestern ja also wie
du es schon gesagt hast es geht
eigentlich genau weiter so bis auf einen
wichtigen punkt und zwar das pcr testen
wird massiv eingeschränkt pcr tests die
zuverlässigen test also der goldstandard
unter den tests der wird jetzt nur noch
verfügbar sein für mitarbeiter von
krankenhäusern von pflegeheimen und auch
für variable gruppen also beispielsweise
menschen die in altenheim leben wir
haben einfach nicht genug tests die
labore sind ausgelastet und deswegen für
uns normalbürger wird es jetzt deutlich
schwerer für npcs zu kommen und 1 1 ein
letzter wichtiger punkt die öffnungs
perspektive das wort öffnungs
perspektive dass so viele menschen
hoffnung macht steht ganz weit oben in
diesem beschluss aber da heißt es man
wird erst eine öffnung perspektive
vorlegen und erst dann lockern wenn der
zusammenbruch des gesundheitssystems
ausgeschlossen ist und das ist natürlich
so schwammig gehalten ich glaube viele
bürger hätten sich an der zahl gewünscht
hätten sich gewünscht dass da steht wenn
die instanzen wieder fallen wie das in
anderen ländern ja auch sichtbar ist
dann lockern wir und gerade steht nur
ganz schwer mich wenn da die überlastung
des gesundheitswesen ausgeschlossen wird
sein kann dann wird gelockert ich glaube
viele wissen gar nicht was das bedeutet
nichts treffen glaube ich dann am 14
februar vielen besucher